فنبدا بهذه التطورات العاجله من القدس اذا
اعلام اسرائيليه تحدث عن مقتل سبعه
اسرائيليين جراء اطلاقه النار في مستوطنه
نبي يعقوب بالقدس اذا باصابه خمسه اخرين
على الاقل جراء اطلاق النار في هذه
المستوطنه في شرق القدس اطلاق النار
مشاهدينا جاء في عقاب حاله من التوتر بين
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين طبعا بعد
التصعيد العسكري الاسرائيلي في جنين كذلك
هو مقتل تسعه فلسطينيين على الاقل في هذا
التصعيد كذلك اذا جرز الان تؤكد همم
يبدوا انها حصل سابقا الحصيله ارتفعت اذا
كما تشاهده على العاجل على العربيه
اصابه 10 اخرين في اطلاق النار في هذه
المستوطنه المستوطنه نبي يعقوب في القدس
عبد العظيم معنا عبر الهاتف عبد الحفيظ
اهلا بك معنا هل همم هذه الحصيله النهائيه
ام هي قابله للارتفاع
لا هي صهيب قابله للارتفاع هناك خمسه قتله
تم تاكيد يعني مقتلهم على الفور في ساحه
الكنيسه التي تمت فيها العمليه وهناك ايضا
اثنين تم الاعلان عنهم في وقت لاحق ليرتفع
عدد القتلى الان الى سبعه هناك ايضا عدد
اخر من الجرحى بعضهم اصابته خطره للغايه
وبالتالي عدد القتلى المرشح للارتفاع من
هذه العمليه المعلومات التي رشحت حتى الان
ان ااه فلسطينيا على ما يبدو من حمله
الهويه الزرقاء من الداخل يترجل من سياره
وادخل الى ساحه كنيسه يهودي في حي النبي
يعقوب الاستيطاني شمال مدينه القدس وقام
باطلاق النار مباشره على عدد من
الاسرائيليين الذين كانوا في المكان الان
الشرطه الاسرائيليه قامت باغلاق كل مداخل
مدينه القدس وتقوم في محاوره البحث على من
اوصل منفذ عمليه اطلاق النار الذي اعلنت
ايضا مصادر في الشرطه الاسرائيليه عن
مقتله همم جراء هذه العمليه طيب اذا انت
تاكد معلومات عن المهاجم وصل الى ساحه
كنيسه يهوديه نحن مشاهدينا نشاهد صور
مباشره بالفعل عبد الحفيظ يتحدث عن اغلاق
جميع المنافذ همم في حي همم النبي يعقوب
او النبي يعقوب في القدس بعد اطلاقا النار
هذه صور على ما يبدو كما نتابع همم سياره
المنفذ كما قال عبد الحفيظ قبل قليل انه
منفذ الهجوم الذي قام الامن الاسرائيلي
بتصفيته كان يقود سياره قام بالخروج منها
وتنفيذ اذا عمليه اطلاق النار التي اودت
بحياه سبعه مستطيل اسرائيليين حتى الان
واا اصابه 10 على الاقل همم فيما يبدو ان
هذه هي سياره المهاجم
صور مباشره اذا المشاهدين مباشره من نبي
يعقوب شرقيه القدس بعد هذه العمليه كما
تشاهدون اثار الرصاص كذلك على زجاج
الامامي للسياره
[موسيقى]
صحيفه
كما نقلت قبل قليل بانه تم تحيد المهاجم
الذي قام بقتل ااا سبعه اسرائيليين على
الاقل مراسلنا تحدث عن وصول المهاجم الى
ساحه كنيس يهودي في حي النبي يعقوب في
القدس والامن الاسرائيلي كما تتابعون الان
يغلق جميع منافذ القدس بعد هذه العمليه
التي تاتي غادتها التصعيد الاسرائيلي
الكبير في جنين في الاراضي الفلسطينيه همم
والذي اودى بحياه تسعه فلسطينيين كذلك
الان كما تتابعون سيارات الاسعاف
الاسرائيليه هي متواجده في المكان
وكمان نتابع هذه على ما يبدو الاغراض التي
كانت في داخل السيارات كما ذكر مراسلون
قبل قليل منفذ الهجوم يبدو انه من حمله
الهويات الزرقاء اي من فلسطينيين الداخل
اااه
بتنفيذ الهجوم كمان متابع اذا هذه صور
مباشره
حي النبي يعقوب في القدس حيث جرت هذه
العمليه عمليه اطلاق نار على همم في مكان
قريب من كنيسه يهودي او ده بحياتها سبعه
اسرائيليين حتى الان واصابه 10 في اطلاق
النار وقامت القوات الاسرائيليه بقتل
المنفذ حتى الان عبد الحفيظ لا تزال معي
نعم يا صهيب غير معروف هذه السياره تحديد
الذي تتحدث عنها لانه هناك ارتباك في
الاخبار يقول انها ربما تكون سياره سائق
المنبه الذي يعني اوصل المنفذ الى المكان
وان الشرطه الاسرائيليه غير معروف مصيرهم
كان ترجل من السياره
وهرى ام ان يعني تم تصفيته هو الاخر في
مكان قريب من العمليه شهود عيان قالوا ان
عمليه اطلاق النار استمرت نحو 30 ثانيه
همم تمت ثور خروج
المستوطنين من داخل الكنيسه كانوا قد
تجمعوا في ساحه الكنيس وانا الهجوم الثوره
همم خروجه من ساحه الكنيسه ايضا هناك صور
تنقل من مستشفى هداسا للمصابين الى هناك
يظهر ان عدد المصابين ايضا كبير هناك حاله
من فوضى داخل المستشفى ومحاوله لانقاذ
المصابين الذين اصيبوا على ما يبدو بعضهم
اصابات خطره الغايه لما الرصافه كان
مباشره من قبل
صحيح كما ذكرت همم نبقى حذيرين مع
المعلومات والصور الوارده همم انا ذكرته
يمكن ان نتوقع ذلك او يمكن ان نبني بناء
ان بعض على بعض المؤشرات عبد الحفيظ
السياره كانت همم عليها اثار رصاص في
الزجاج الامامي لها ونحن ما نزل نشاهد ال-
الصور الان على مقربه من هذه السياره ان
تتحدث على ان ربما يكون هناك شخصان يعني
شخص كان يقود السياره اوصل المنفذ الذي
ترجى من السياره وقام باطلاق النار فيما
اخر همم ذهب ام ماذا هذه هي يعني الروايه
الاوليه يقول حسب
شرطه الاسرائيليه لمنفذ العمليه تم تصفيته
في مكان قريب من العمليه الان المنفذ
الاخر او السائق الذي اوصل منفذ العمليه
الى المكان مصيره مجهول حتى هذه اللحظه
على ما يبدو شويه ايضا ثقيله من مصادر
صحفيه انا اهتمت بمسدس وليس بسلاح رشاش
كما اعتقد البعض وان المنفذ يعني يتكلم
مسدسهم من السياره واقام باطلاق النار
بشكل مباشر على المستوطنين الموجودين داخل
همم وفي صحه هذا الكنيسه الاسرائيلي في حي
بني يعقوب في القدس الشرقيه طيب همم
معلومات على ما يبدو يشارلي انه اعلام
اسرائيلي يتحدث عن ارتفاع الحصيله الى
تسعه اسرائيليين قتلوا في هذه العمليه اذا
اليوم في مستوطنه نبي يعقوب في القدس
القناه الثالثه عشر حتى الان تؤكد انهم
ثمانيه اصبحوا نعم ثمانيه القناه
للارتفاع طيب حدثني عن هذا الكنيسه هل هنا
لديك معلومات اكثر حول الكنيسه اليهودي
همم الموجود في النبي يعقوب الذي قام مطلق
النار باطلاق النار فيه
يهودي عادي في هذا الحيه
وفي القصه الشرقيه وكما قلت يعني حي النبي
يعقوب يسكنه يهود متدينون على السكان
وتقريبا 30,000 مستوطن يسكن في هذا الحي
وبالتالي همم هناك همم قبيل يوم السبت
هناك تجمعات للمستوطنين الذين يقومون
بالصلاه في هذا الكنيسه على ما يبدو ان
المنفذ كان الدراسه المكان ويعني اختار
توقيت وقت الصلاه وقت الخروج من الصلاه
لتنفيذ هذه العمليه التي يعني كما كنا
صهيب انا تاتي في رد على ال ال الجنين
عمليه ردود الفعل الان يعني يمكن ان
نرصدها ايضا
على الهواء مباشره السياره همم لا نعلم
مشاهدينا نحن نبقى فقط تحديدا نحن نحاول
ان نستنتج من هذه المشاهد اذا كانت هذه
سياره منفذ الهجوم ام لا يمكن الجزم بذلك
بعد ولكن تشاهدون بشكل جلي اثار الرصاص
على واجهه السياره همم فيما يرجح همم ربما
يجعلنا استنتج انها يمكن ان تكون سياره
المنفذ او شخصيه سياره الشخص الذي قام
بنقل همم منفذ الهجوم كما تشاهدون ايضا
الزجاج همم في السياره كذلك مهشم جرى همم
طبعا فتح همم السياره من كل ابوابها
واخراج جميع مقتنيات الموجوده بداخلها
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه تحدثت عن همم
تحييد منفذ هذا الهجوم نتحدث اذا عن سياره
بيضاء كمان نشاهد في هذه الصور همم واغلاق
جميع منافذ القدس كما تشاهدون اذن من بعيد
همم طبعا همم سيارات الشرطه والاسعاف
موجوده في كل مكان همم بعد طبعا ارتفاع
هذه الحصيله كما ذكر عبد الحفيظ لنا قبل
قليل بان همم حاله من الهلع موجوده او
تسيطر على المكان بعد عمليه اطلاق النار
هذه همم بالقرب من كنيسيا يهودي في مستوط
نه يعقوب في القدس